yeah they must go cool like and Dragon
Ball Z cuz I'm a big fan of Dragon Ball
your son GQ on my 10 essentials my
playstation I can live a [ __ ] when I go
and talk to like my best friend because
if I don't bring the taste this and I
feel like I'm a slave of my words
basically every time I get on the plane
I'll put the TV and I put the
PlayStation IV and I'll be playing my
favorite game right now is 2k 20 there -
20 20 feet by gang and I'm like a little
kid with the Dragon Ball Z games that's
a part of the aisle I never go alone so
I'm always playing there's one of those
sitting basically I'm always playing ok
so one of my legs essential is this
little bag it's like where you put the
watches I love the jewelry I love the
watches I have a lot of money invested
in watches when I buy watches I'll make
sure like a year could go by and us
they're gonna have the same price the
same value or maybe water they said we
have this keeping me here you put them
all right Lacey I got like J like 6
watts or 7 yeah when I started to buy
watches I used to scratch them a lot
when you scratch them they use bad news
so I used to take them off and put like
anywhere basically so goodbye to you so
when I don't have it all I'm just
keeping the safe here okay my nexus
thing so it's like like a son to me my
dog he's a English bulldog
it's a little bit like me my little baby
still I gotta be taking care of him
this type of dog comes with all types of
problems so basically I'm always having
it in check seeing to get he ain't
getting sick none of that
I can't wait friend and grow up and they
grow up dig you don't get that much
thought but he getting really fast yeah
so yeah I can't wait for any soul of
mine existential is like this you'll be
back he's working on machine this was
like the first Shane about when I came
out of prison it's like the devil and
Jesus like fighting and I'm a really
spiritual person so all my shame is that
I'm my way back yeah one of the most
important essentials for me I love the
jewelry of the time okay my night system
so this Lamborghini has to be James I
can be giving can I kick Cara Mia but I
got the key right here it's the type of
car that basically I would want to take
it to every city every country just my
manager says don't be like that you
wanna throw away money I'm gonna be
doing that I get fat can I live in the
house
like a Google pilot and basically had
nothing like sometimes we'd be going out
right and there's me and all my friends
instead it's just going in my car I'll
be cutting like now they call the cars I
give around all my keys and you see yeah
we'd be putting off in the Lambo the
rolls-royce the like all the other cars
even sometimes we go out in the in the
motorcycle and I'm like not follow us
and all the cars I'm getting the key
there some a little too extra bit here
my next essential is the joy now
basically this goal is but I can't bring
down all my shoes or my sneakers
basically I'm a sneaker free when I go
on tour I bring like like two different
bags that can fit each back and be like
twelve different pair of sneakers out of
24 22 I join and so I love Jordans life
where I'm from like the Jordan having
Jordan it's like really part of the
culture so this is really essential for
me out I'm always up and down to Jordan
I charted not wearing too much data type
of shoe that if you want you don't want
to get them to birdie you don't use them
too much but if you don't use them too
much
you gotta like wrap them up basically
cuz the Jordans I don't know why this
type of sneaker you know wrap they'd
great lately I just do I just buy two
pairs of each sneakers so I just get one
to do whatever basically up and not like
on the daily and the other one I'd say
below certain occasions my nice
essential is to be honest now you look
for music like variety but sometimes I
know I go through airport I know there's
gonna be a lot of people with and I'll
be putting them on just to play it cool
like you know people spiral speed your
baby back and so sometimes you know
there's so lately like basically you
ain't feeling that good you know
so basically I just put these on it yeah
and I put the music on it I'll forget
about it
my next essential rent is this laptop I
just take the laptop away and I probably
did so whatever setup I got to record
and basically this is where I got all my
music this where I got totaled all the
projects yeah basically this laptop
yeah means a lot to me I never think
they were basic cuz I'm always working
my life decision to speak because
everywhere I go out we've gotta have
music right so if I owned a hotel get
ready please show up in the speaker's
off and pump in the house with with God
and the whole family we just buy paint
or drinking or having fun
put the music on basically everywhere my
sister gotta be currently like if it was
I like yeah so one of the things I can
live without is this microphone it's
like a really good microphone that even
if you went into a big studio it was
gonna sound like invited us to this
microphone yes we finished thank you GQ
for checking out my ten essentials hope
you liked them god bless ya
you